[Music]
all right so uh welcome everybody to
this uh
lecture on end games it's technically
called
insane that really hypes it up
i don't think you guys are gonna go
insane from these end games that i'm
about to show you but hopefully
uh you will get a deeper appreciation of
end games and especially the way that
i like to talk about end games is
i like to use them as case studies
of strategy one analogy that i like to
use especially with kids because i work
with kids all the time is you know
nobody no kids study end games they all
hate end games
right and you ask them you know our end
game is important they're like yes of
course of course they're studying so
never
like i just do openings and tactics all
the time
and i'm like well if you think it's
important why don't you study them he's
like well if i study an endgame
what are the probabilities that i'm
going to actually get it in one of my
games
and they you know they make a pretty
good argument they say if i do get it
and i mess it up maybe that's half a
point or a full point that i leave on
the board
and like that's in my entire career like
maybe get one chance
i'm like well that's not really the
point right like
you do tactics problems yeah i do tons
of tactics well you don't
solve a tactics puzzle because you think
you're gonna
get that position in one of your games
right so
it's the same thing with end games like
you do tactics to train your calculation
you do end games to train your strategic
understanding
so whereas tactics it's just about being
able to visualize positions
and calculate your way through
variations
in end games what you're supposed to do
is
find ways of getting all your pieces to
collaborate
towards a common goal which is basically
the definition of strategy
right so this is one of my favorite end
games to try to
exercise that skill it's a it's a very
famous theoretical end game it's called
the philidor end game it's one of
philidor's many end games that he
analyzed
i think it was like 17th century or
late 16th century something like that
it's insane
like this guy has to be top three
greatest test players of all time
he was a famous composer during his time
as well
and i guess when he wasn't composing he
was just
cranking out all these end games that
stand until today
even though you have engines and all
sorts of uh strong grandmasters and
nobody can improve upon his solutions
it's just mind-boggling
anyway this is one of his famous
positions
and i really like it because
when you find this end game in an
endgame book the solution is like
impossible
uh if you try to memorize it it's just
like
trying to memorize a phone book or
something like that it's just variation
after variation
very difficult so one of the things that
i like to do with endgames is try to
break down those
long convoluted solutions and articulate
it into words like what's
really going on so i like to
divide this end game into two stages
and stage number one is going to involve
dominating this rook domination is
the holy grail of strategy it's the
process by which you
gradually improve your pieces while
restricting your opponents right in this
case black doesn't have that many pieces
so in the first part of the end game
black's
rook needs to be driven from its optimal
square where it is at right now
to its worst possible square now it's
hard
to figure out what square is actually
the worst possible square so this is
where it's handy to actually know the
solution beforehand
because it gives you important
information now does anybody
have any idea as to what that worst
square might be for this rook
somewhere on the back of the light
square somewhere on the
the eighth rank somewhere on the eighth
rank that would be a good guess now
why i think maybe we should start with
why e7 is the optimal square
and then we can sort of reverse engineer
that and and try to deduce what the
worst square would be yeah in the back
in case there's any like checks
exactly so what the rook on e7 allows
you to do
is to meet check with block
and if white doubles back and swings
over to the other side
then you can also swing over to the
other side and block
the check again so black is doing a sort
of rope-a-dope and wherever
whichever side of the board you come at
him from he's going to swing the rook
and block the check that way so this is
the essence
of black's defense here and
that's why it's so important for the
rook to be on e7 for example if it were
if it were black to move and black we
were to place the rook on the back rank
which would be
really devastating like like you're
saying well now i would swing over
to the other side and your rook can't
make it in time
to block the checks so you lose the end
game so
in a way the forcing the rook
to the back rank would be ideal but we
can't actually do that
uh can't unless black does it willingly
which would not be
a good idea would be very cooperative
and very thoughtful
but not very good another important
defensive resource you might think well
if this is the idea why don't i just
take that square
away from the rook and now i'm
threatening check well here black has
this very nice
stalemate trick rook d7
and after bishop takes this is a draw so
these two ideas are going to be
the essence of black's defensive
strategy and this is what we're going to
have to overcome
if we want to win this endgame so
spoiler alert the worst square for the
black rook i'm not telling you this
because
i don't think i could even figure this
out if you gave me like if i'd never
seen this position before and you gave
it to me it would take me a million
years and it probably wouldn't figure it
out
is the c3 square
what yes it sounds ridiculous
but if we can get this black rook to c3
the game is over and then it just
becomes a matter of applying some
tactical themes and then it's just a
matter it's like a force when it's a
matter of
of raw calculation more than really
understanding where the pieces need to
go
so it's a fascinating end game because
the first part is pure strategy
and the second part is pure tactics so
we need to gradually push this rook
closer and closer to the c3 square and
we're gonna do this
in stages we're gonna do this gradually
so what would be the first step
how would you guys play this end game
yeah
in the back
okay vague knowledge is great because
it's usually going to get you halfway
and then
something bad happens and and it falls
apart so this is where most people are
they acknowledge uh so what
what is that vague knowledge
okay so let's say after rook f2
i just may waste the tempo with my well
actually here
i might be able to to check you right uh
i don't actually have to waste
ten point as white i wouldn't be
particularly happy
to have my king uh dislodged from d6
because that's really an optimal square
for the king that's why it was also
tempting to play bishop c6
to keep the rook at bay
so so not only is the rook ideally
placed here it's also threatening to
interrupt the coordination among our
pieces yeah
um so i also have a big knowledge of
this end game uh
i actually have studied this before but
actually i've forgotten everything for
some reason
perfect this is my kind of crowd vague
knowledge i knew it but i forgot it so
i'm actually going to be able to show
you some
idea i can't stuff uh rook fade i guess
first and then ricky
would be the way that i would okay great
so notice how
we're making progress right one of the
things that
that you shouldn't do in end games is
visualize
the the end position that you want and
try to get there right away
because you might miss a defensive
resource
you might rush things and you have to be
patient
um you want to really grind your
opponent down
you're not in a rush i mean unless you
have something else you need to do that
day but otherwise
you know really black has no counter
play so you can take
all the time in the world actually not
true
i remember karuana got this end game
against svidler at the candidates
a few years a few years ago
and he drew it because he was one move
shy like he he reached the 50 moves and
he was winning on the 51st
and he makes the 50 and fiddler's like
arbiter uh
bail me out you know cash me in i'm done
and he couldn't make it uh so actually
you might have to hurry a little bit but
from once you get to this position it is
a forced win so he actually had to
maneuver a lot to get here
and that's what really did him in uh
because the end game is
technically a draw if you don't get here
so
what were you saying after you you get
the seventh rank then what do you do
well what does black do actually what is
white threatening ken
what is white threatening yes you got
this
uh bishop to c6
and if rook h8
then remember what the purpose of the
rook on e7
was why that was the perfect square and
why
this is less than perfect
what is the essence of black's defense
what is that rook supposed to be able to
do well
why what does e7 allow you to
allow you access to simultaneously
it allows you to shuttle back and forth
between the king side and the queen side
so for example if you get checked here
you can black here
but if you get checked here you need to
be able to block here
so white is actually threatening to
swing the rook over
and mate you so for example if you were
to make a random move here like rook h8
this would be losing because now after
this you can't block the check in time
you can give it check
but then i block it and you're done
right so
how can black solve this problem
fortunately it's black to move
so it's not quite over yet
king c8 and what if i um
because if i go here then you might have
this check still
so maybe throwing in this in between
check
uh works right because if king d8 then i
get to play rook a7 so you would you
have to go king b8
rook b7 now if i go here i'm going to
lose the rook
so i have to go back to c8
and now rook here so i'm threatening
bishop e6 followed by rook b8
and if check
king c6 and
here oh this is going to be a close one
because if i go here again i lose right
so i have to go here
yeah right attack the rook in here so
this looks like a win
so
what does black have to do yeah in the
back
yeah any kind of any kind of move that
would allow this rook to swing over
and cover the c8 square we're going to
see
that our goal is to actually trace
the path of this rook we want it to go
first to e8 so we pick up the seventh
rank
then we want to force it to e3 and then
we want to force it to c3 so we're going
to
slowly nudge it in the direction that we
want it so
first things first step one we pick up
the seventh rank
now if black is cooperative
you will play rook e3 and when we swing
the rook over
the rook swings over and we get the rook
to where we want it don't ask me why
it's bad on c3 we're going to get around
to that in just a moment
but for now take a leap of faith and
trust me that this is a terrible square
for the black rook so assuming that
let's say
that black just moves the rook as far
away as possible
generally a good policy for the rook
right so after rookie one oops
white wastes actually i have rook e2 as
the main move because
rook h7 is the main move because rookie
2 is actually a very good square
for this rook and e1
is not as good actually the reason
for that is again solely based on the
assumption that we want to get this rook
to e3
is that if i swing the rook over
and now you swing the rook over to c2
i need to take away these two squares
from you so that you will have to go to
c3
and if i try to take the c2 square away
then you can give me a check now what
happens
if i were to force your rook to e1 well
when i swing the rook over now
and you go rook c1 i can play bishop
here
your rook can't stay on c1 because you
have to make a move
it can't go to c2 or d1 so it would have
to go
to c3 and then our mission is
accomplished and
we would move on to step two so
let's see what happens if black doesn't
cooperate if black plays rookie two
right we waste a move very useful
technique in the end game when your
opponent has his ideal defense in place
one of the questions that you should ask
yourself is what happens if i just
you know waste the move and throw the
ball back in his court what is he going
to do oftentimes
when you have your dream position the
worst thing that could happen to you
is to have to play again like you've
already peaked
right so you kind of want your opponent
to come at you at that moment
and that's when you sort of dodge and uh
and let
your opponent's position fall under its
own weight
so after rook h7
only really two options in terms of
moving the rook we already know that
rookie three
is basically what we want rookie one
we're going to look at in a moment
but what happens if black says well i
don't want to waste a tempo with my rook
i want to move my king well here it's
very easy because this is check made in
one move
right the bishop's very useful taking
away the escape square on f7
and what happens if king c8 this is
trickier
it goes nowhere right you have to block
and you also get mated so
you really don't have options you have
to move the rook
rookie 8 again loses to rook a7 or yeah
rook a7
so you have to go rook e1
now the rook swings over to the other
side
why might it be b might b7 be a better
square than a7
right it would seem like the most normal
move here would be to go again as far
away as you can go
right i'm threatening checkmate so we
know what black's next move is going to
be
well but if you go if you go to b1 i
still have this check
right so the rook always has to go to
the
adjacent file to the king because the
king has to support
the defense
so i have to play rook c1 so what would
be the next step
in in luring we've done a pretty good
job we
drove the rook to e8 then to e1
then to c1 and we want to get it to c3
so we're
we're almost we're almost home
yes sir right if we play bishop here
now when black moves the rook to c3 we
can't
really play with as much freedom
as if we had our rook on b7 protecting
our bishop because here black is
threatening to take black is threatening
check
so the point of having the rook on b7 is
to keep your bishop defended
and this is sort of the mindfulness that
you need to have in
end games where you need all of your
pieces to work together
the rook swings over but it has to have
an eye on the bishop
right the bishop needs backup too in
order for all of the pieces to work
together
you know the rook can't just cut loose
and say well i'm doing my thing
and you know help out if you can and
we'll meet at the finish line no
so rook
b7 is the key move uh
what if king c8 now what if black
resists
right this idea
[Music]
right and this is going to be checkmate
so all the pieces working together very
nice
and you're saying if i go rook d1
um
so if he plays uh you mean here rook d1
rook a4
and if i okay that's a good idea and if
i go here
right if you go check i still have this
move right so here
actually you can play rook a7
you're threatening checkmate in one move
so that pretty much forces black's hand
to play rook b1
and now
king b7
yeah it's a slippery king yep
bishop and if i
play rook b2
okay so let's say rook uh rook h7 yeah
and then b8 then i just go from
excellent right so now it turns out this
rook
is in trouble i'm threatening checkmate
you can't go back because your rook's
not able to block the check
uh if you give a check here i'll just
block it with the bishop so the only
move is king b8
check can hear check and this would
normally be fine because the king
escapes
if not for the skewer here where you
lose the rook
exactly so
so the tactics all seem to work out so
we have the the sort of framework
of the idea that black needs to always
be able to play which is to swing over
with the rook from the e file to the c
file
and the reason you can sort of see it
you know if you read between the lines
these are the tactics that make that
idea so necessary
so you don't actually need to know the
tactics you know once you know the idea
but then once you understand the end
game you can
zoom in and sort of check okay this is
why that happens
and so on so the rook has to go over to
c1
so the next move should is is pretty
hard but i think
since we've been talking about it it's
kind of uh
i mean i'm sure you guys can
what's that rook b2 no no no i'm sorry
bishop b3 yes bishop b3
because we have to force this rook to c3
and well rook c3 is the main move
but again let's ask ourselves what
happens what alternatives does black
have well
king eight is not much of an alternative
because you self-mate yourself
and what about king c8 hitting the rook
this move makes
some sense
well bishop d5 we're just going to end
up repeating
yeah repeating moves
well remember this everything is uh is
going according to plan for black right
there
yeah because the bishop's no longer
cutting it off
well i don't know if anywhere um but
let's choose one square and take it from
there
rook b6 okay and
let's say
oh
any other ideas i saw some hands up in
the back
okay here in the chat we have the
suggestion of rook b4 which is actually
the best move i'm not saying the other
moves
don't win but actually rook b5 would
probably be the worst move
because we're going to see that this
bishop we're going to get
every last drop of play that we can out
of this bishop
but in general in the end game you have
to do that you have to get the most out
of every one of your pieces
which is going to involve multitasking
right
a lot of the times when you're in the
opening or in the middle game
you can afford to have a piece slacking
off not doing anything because you have
so many pieces
that the other pieces can pick up the
slack you know it's like
um like a like a basketball analogy
you have five players you can have four
really good ones and one of them maybe
not so good
well it kind of gets buried under the
fact that you have four really good
players but in the end game
as you start simplifying the position
it's more of a one-on-one
so you know you've got nobody to pick up
the slack you've got to bring your
a game so you can't afford to have
pieces
idling yeah in the back so the
ratio
yeah i mean i don't know if it's that
mathematical but
you know each position is different so
maybe you'll be able to get away with
having a piece that's not as active as
it could be
but in general what you have to have is
this mentality of always
being alert for opportunities to
bring pieces that aren't doing anything
into the game or maybe if it's a piece
that's in the game but could be better
you know just always trying to improve
the pieces and always trying to bring
them all in
don't get too focused on one single
piece or two single pieces thinking oh i
can just make it happen with these two i
don't need to
to get everybody in so the move here is
rook b4
which creates a very nasty threat we're
threatening bishop e6 check
followed by rook b8 and rook takes c8
checkmate there's no check
on d1 so the only move is for the king
to go back
and now how do we
all continue got to do is create the
books well
easier said than done so actually
now we swing over to the other side
right so again we're threatening
checkmate what would be the
thematic move for black here rookie one
right this would be
the normal move if king c8
what happens
bishop d5 we're renewing the threat of
checkmate the king can't go back because
the rook is on the wrong file
only move king b8 and now
rook a4 and now you're going to get
mated here
and your rook can't make it in time
to cover the check you're just getting
checkmated
so
the rook has to go to e1
and now it is time for our bishop
to blossom and show us its full
potential yes
way in the back was that a hand or was
it a shadow
it's very dark back there okay never
mind
uh any ideas
bishop a4 bingo now the bishop
controls the check on d1 but it also
takes away this key defensive square for
the rook
so it disrupts your defense completely
wait a minute not done yet right i can
still i can still move
my king
yep bishop c6
this is so easy here
bishop d5 and
again if i go king d8 i get mated i
can't play rookie one i have to go king
b8
again same idea all right and let's do
maybe one more after bishop c6 well
here
again right same thing you're still
going to get mated and after check
bishop d5 just transposes right
so
after bishop a4 that's it this is just a
beautiful position that illustrates
the essence of this end game you're
getting the most out of your king
at the same time you're getting the most
out of your bishop
who is protecting your king's position
making sure it doesn't get dislodged
from d6
by covering d1 disrupting black's
defensive setup by covering e8 and then
you're also getting the most out of your
rook
constantly shuttling back and forth
between kingside and queenside so
this overwhelms black's defense and
causes it to collapse
now i think we're finally ready to move
on
to the second part of this end game the
easy part this is the hard part because
this is the part that you actually have
to understand
so
instead of king c8 black says okay have
it your way
i'll go to c3 what's the big deal about
this
and the interesting thing about this
position is that in order to win
with white we're going to need to employ
three
tactical themes triangulation
one i don't remember and a curtain i'm
going to remember it eventually but i'm
getting just so
nervous with our millions of viewers
here it's uh
it's difficult what's that eventually
millions
avenge what do you mean eventually i s
this counter does not lie
uh yeah
so what we're going to try to do now
that the rook
is on c3 is we're going to try to
dominate this rook
so that once again this defensive setup
that black has put together
will not hold up so
uh can anybody make a suggestion as to
how you would continue here with white
yeah
okay so let's say i do go rook d3
bishop d5 and now i go back
um
and you gotta start all over again
um no but actually here maybe you have
this move
right which is kind of the whole point
of luring the rook to c3
you're interfering with the defense and
the bishop is once again interfering
with the defense of you know
the back rank but also making sure that
this king
cannot be attacked so in a way it's the
same idea as the bishop
on a4 that we just saw it's just adapted
to a slightly different position
yes let's let's say that it is i still
can't remember it but
yeah it is interference actually so you
have triangulation curtain interference
those are the big three
um now let's see
after rook b4 what happens if instead of
giving this check
i just go back to c1 saying oof that was
close
let me get out of this troubling c3
square
how are you gonna
oh and actually i don't know what i'm
doing why don't i go here
right same idea as as the initial
position
arguing that the rook the rook's ideal
squares are e7 and c7
and i also have this idea now
can you play bishop a4
all right check yeah oh and it said
stanley
yep
well i think here you kind of have to
start all over again but from the other
side
right so so that's kind of frustrating
so i don't think the move rook before
is the key so actually
the first step the first step is going
to be triangulation
this um oh no no it wasn't it wasn't
interference you tricked me
you tricked me it's a it's the in
in-between move
uh to dislocate uh the opponent's
position
um so and then the curtain is actually
another word for interference
yeah it's like you interfere so you
bring down like a curtain i guess
yeah i got i got like a b minus in that
test
so triangulation right
the move is bishop e6 which seems like
such
a grotesque move because it creates the
obvious threat of checkmate so you're
basically
asking to get checked but now
after bishop d5 it turns out this rook
is not particularly well placed right so
what we're trying to do is
we're trying to get to this position
with white to move
right actually we're trying to get to
this position
with white to move if it was white to
move this would be an easy win
and we'll see why in just a moment so
the idea is
after bishop e6 you're forcing this
check and after bishop d5 you're hoping
that black will play rook c3 and there
you have it
right and you really don't have much of
a choice as to
rook c3 because again this runs into
checkmate and your only
real alternative is king to c8
and what do you do against king to c8
go i mean you're over there is my over
ahead of
on the screen
h7
and if and if i go if i go here i don't
really have much of a choice
right because now there's no rook on b1
right so this idea of
check check check really uh doesn't
doesn't pay off as big
um well
what would black normally want to do
ah this is why you don't want to be on
the third rank right this is why c3 is
bad because the bishop from d5
is going to prevent this rook from
dropping back to some critical squares
to block the checkmate
so the leap of faith has paid off and
we're beginning to see
why the third rank and the c3 square in
particular
is so problematic so now there's just no
stopping
rook a8 so the rook has to go back
to c3 so triangulation
check now
comes the trickier part and it's nice
because they go in like
increasing levels of difficulty these
these tactical themes so you got through
the first hurdle
now the in-between move
it seems like everything is a-okay for
black right the defense is holding up
we've got the king here
the rook is ready to block the check and
the rook is also ready to swing over and
block the check
on the other side as long as black can
keep this up black survives
bingo rook d7 this is an incredibly
annoying check
because now wherever the king goes the
rook is going to have to
uh sort of hustle and and say well wait
let me i'm not getting there in time
right you went to the wrong side
for example let's see again why the
third rank is so terrible if king e8
what do we do now rook g7
beautiful so now we're threatening
checkmate and uh oh
the bishop is dominating the rook once
again
so the the reason that we wanted to lure
the rook to c3
is because it's within reach of the
bishop if the rook were on c1 or c2
it would just be right out of the
bishop's capabilities
right so the rook would be able to swing
over and maintain the defense
so no choice but to go to the other side
and here rook a7 again
the rook is dominated can't block the
check
um well actually no wait it can still go
here
yeah hold on
you guys are testing me today
so rook a7 just repeats the position
right i mean the king goes back to d8 no
problem
okay so let's say we go all the way here
only move
yeah you got it
right so for example check here uh rook
moves here
right so so i mean here you're
threatening check and check right but i
can still go king
king here and and block
oh you want to keep going here uh what
am i doing so here
here you what was your move i was
looking at
bishop to um
right and now okay check
yes sorry what's wrong with rook a7
uh here the king goes back
right can you please can you play rook
before
ah very thoughtful uh right
rook v2 is a selfish move is the rook
doing well i'll do my thing you go
check and then you know everything gets
incommunicated but rook b4
keeps in touch with the bishop because
now we're still threatening
check followed by checkmate so black
still has to go king d8
and now
the rook this is the interference slash
curtain right because now the rook
cannot access
c8 we are threatening checkmate there is
no check
on d3 and if the king goes back then we
give this check
and check mate
so
let's go back here so we did the
triangulation
now we do the in between move
and we finish the game off with the
interference
so that's how you wrap up these three
themes
into one single uh sort of sequence
and those are the two parts of the end
game i think that breaking it down like
this makes it
not only easier to know which is really
not the point yeah
you have a question back there yeah it's
like kind of related what would happen
if the
bishop was a dark square bishop well you
would just have to move everything one
file right so for example
in the initial position instead of
having this you would need like the king
on e6 and the bishop on e5
so the beauty of this solution is that
it works
on all these
files actually um
i think it's a draw if you're on the
night files
and it might be a win i don't remember
on the rook files but it's a totally
different solution
and it's really not so much fun yeah
um
oh i think i remember that yeah i
completely forgot about it
uh what that was with gareth
yeah yes and karana lost that game
and then uh
gray of cevion i don't know we're going
to need our fact checkers
here uh to chime in because i
vaguely remember that that game a few
years ago at the us championships
keyboard was playing gada
what happened in uh the game oh god i
want so yeah okay so
he got away with it it wasn't an easy
reputation you know yeah well i guess he
didn't have an outburst
uh in that in that game
um okay so anyway what i was saying
about this end game and this is
generally what
i think is fruitful of studying end
games
is that it's not just about oh now if i
get this i know what to do
i mean i've been studying this end game
for years
i've never gotten it in a single game
and it's and it's not even a problem
like i'm not even sorry that i didn't
get it
i would actually be afraid to get it
because i maybe i won't have time and
i'll mess it up and i'll feel i'll feel
stupid
because i've seen it so many times but
really it helps you think
about you know how to get your pieces to
collaborate with each other now this is
a very difficult endgame from a
theoretical point of view
i would say that it's only
second to is anybody familiar
with the end game
[Music]
king rook and rook pawn
against king and bishop
yes you drew that
with the rooker in the pawn or with the
bishop it's harder to draw with the
bishop uh
yeah and um
yeah and when you went into the game
like when you went into the end game on
what rank was your opponent's rook pawn
it was on the third rank so so he was
actually winning
it's actually winning if it's on the
third rank well i mean let's
uh actually let's put it on the board
because this is
the end game that i had in mind for next
week's lecture so this can
can work as a little bit of an
introduction i'm trying to i'm trying to
ease you into this nightmare this bear
of an end game
well it's easier to play it when you
have the bishop you just like
i actually had that end game with the
rook and the pawn and i was sweating it
uh
because uh well let's uh let's actually
take a look how do i do this board
editor
clear board the really tough position
is something like this
let's give black a bishop
and rook actually
oh hi is this a is this right i think
my my engine was the other was the other
one so my ship was on the right
the right wait so what was what was your
end game actually
i was white i had a dark colored bishop
my king was like on a2 or something
my bishop was on b my bishop was on b2
yeah my phone hadn't fought hard um
my opponent's pawn was like on a4
eventually went to a3 later
okay but where was it when you went into
the end game was it here or here
at some point or did was it already
there when you went into it
oh okay i don't remember which one
so let's get that's too many two man
that's that's easy
that's too easy anyway let's say you
know
uh whatever just let's put a rook here
and let's put a king here this is an
easy draw
for white yeah easy easy peasy
uh the
the trick is to avoid advance
avoid advancing your your a pawn the end
game is a win
if your pawn is at least on the fourth
rank or farther back
right so paws on uh
a7 a6 or a5 is a win
pawn on a4 a3 or a2 is a draw
you basically have no way of making
progress as white and actually it'd be
interesting just to
to take a quick look at that right with
the pawn on a4
and play it out just so you see how
difficult this is
this is going to be so let's see
here right so it's white to move let's
say i go check
watch watch you guys just win this
easily with black
oh so you were on the wrong corner oh
okay so then
then it's great then it's maybe not so
easy
um any case we'll come back to that but
basically
you can't break this fortress because uh
well i mean here i'm i'm very close to
winning this pawn right so if you go
here i still can't go king a3 because of
rook b3
so maybe that's still that's still some
hope what's that
bishop here okay and uh
i mean i'll play this with white i'll
i'll take anybody
come on come at me
step right up who thinks you can you can
win this end game i'll find a way to
lose it
well that's tough i mean that would be
impressive
you could figure it out uh if you put
your mind to it you can accomplish
anything
okay and let's say whatever
check here
and i guess i'll go here
king where d3 here
so here yeah okay let's say i keep
moving my bishop
because if you go here that's very cute
but i'm going to take the pawn
instead of the rook
i'm in the perfect corner as white
because this bishop covers this square
and i can
you know i can just
i'm
you can give me the pun i'll take it we
can get whatever position you want this
is a draw either way
if it's like pure special wouldn't you
rather be
like with the dark bishops so that
eventually you know you played bishops
you wanted to stalemate
i'm trying to get rid of my apon in the
way oh i see i see what you mean
um yeah no you're right
actually i don't know what i was saying
yeah but i don't
know
can you actually take advantage of that
here
i don't know probably not
because you're right technically the
good bishop would be the light square
bishop
yeah well i know because that's what i
got in the game
so that's even easier
always trying to challenge myself
i don't even realize it sometimes um
yeah but i think even this position is
probably a draw
i don't know i would have to check that
actually because now
they wrote the bishop because in the
white yeah
yeah that's uh that pawn is not going
anywhere
so
this is my understanding of this endgame
and it'll be the sort of the the intro
because i want to spend
the next lecture really getting into the
nitty-gritty stuff
when the pawn is actually on the fourth
rank usually
the farther back the pawn is the easier
it is to win
because you need to be able uh
to do two things and let me just set up
one more position
so so let's say the end game that i'm
familiar
with i'm going to change this slightly
would be something like this
and
i think is it yeah i think it is the
light square bishop so the problem that
you need to solve as white
is that you need to do two things
simultaneously
you need to keep this king cut off you
can't let this king
reach the h-file because then it's
a fortress and you need to get your king
out of the way
the problem is there's no good way of
doing both things at the same time
because when you get
when you try to get your king out you
allow the black king back in
so so this is the logical problem
that you need to solve and there's some
very
deep ideas in order to do this
and it all has to do with how advanced
this pawn is so anyway
i don't really want to give it away but
i do want to give you a little taste
so that you'll come back next week um so
anyway that's uh
that's basically what i what i had uh to
show you
uh for today uh i hope you enjoyed it i
hope it serves as a good introduction
for our discussion on endgames and also
even if you don't come back next week
hopefully when you come across an end
game you'll start thinking about it
you know you'll look at you'll play over
a solution you'll be like okay let me
put this into words
and then let me see how each piece
interacts with the other one uh in the
correct solution and that way you know
you'll you'll realize what the essence
of the endgame is yeah
can you repeat that so like if it's king
and pawn versus
king in two nights that's actually not a
not such a hard end game and the best
explanation
i've seen of that end game is on
wikipedia
um because it shows you a diagram
of where the pawn needs to be blockaded
for it to be a win and it has a special
name i think the guy that solved it
what indian is it's the two nights
against pawn
where where you need to well technically
with two knights you can't
you can't check mate but if white has a
pawn
you can sort of stalemate him in time so
that he has to start moving the pawn and
then your other knight
comes marching in and you give like this
cool checkmate
i remember there was a high profile game
that happened not too long ago maybe a
couple of years
oh yeah yeah well how doesn't even he's
like the chuck norris
of chess you know it's like
the other day i mean uh i think they
were interviewing him and they're like
you know everybody's pretty rusty you
know haven't been playing he's like no
i'm fine it's like
when when there's no chest chest gets
rusty i don't get rusty you know that
kind of
but he said he was it check out went to
europe and played
and they were able to go country to
country with their coded passport
oh uh oh i didn't know that yeah so okay
so that's was it
i don't know he played a lot
he played in europe yeah no no i mean he
was he was in good form he played really
well in the us junior
so i'm pretty sure that i saw
two nights in the pawn i mean like one
of those sort of
smaller grand master terms they have
like a spring classic or something like
that
the person with a nice one
makes sense yeah um
it all has to do with how far advanced
the pawn is because
you basically need some time for your
knight to get back into the
into the action once you've sort of
stalemated the king
and and white can't queen and bring the
queen
like to the defense so basically when
when white plays queen
you need to play knight checkmate and
for example if the pawn is too far
advanced you only have like three tempe
it's no good
usually i think the pawn needs to be
blockaded on the sixth or fifth rank
at the most advanced right if it's on
the fourth
then it's already a draw yeah
actually uh let me let me just pull that
up on wikipedia
uh because it has a really helpful
diagram
so two
knights versus pawn end game
uh let's see
yeah so this is the the trotsky line
this is basically where you need to
blockade the pawn on each
on each file in order to be able to win
so um you know you can actually maneuver
with your king and knight
as long as you keep the pawn blockaded
here for example if your opponent has
has an a pawn you can actually get away
with with it being
pretty advanced if it's a b pawn not so
much and so on
so i think this is a pretty useful
diagram that gives you an idea you know
when you're going to be winning or not
um so so see here that the pawn is
blockaded on g6
so pawn is blockade on g6 it's a win for
white
and uh yeah i guess the most dangerous
ones are the rook pawns and the center
pawns
uh those actually the least dangerous
one right because
technically if you blockade these with a
knight here here
here here you're still winning
[Music]
you